tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono famiglia e oggi siamo subito
incredibile perché abbiamo provato a
creare un razzo provato a creare un'auto
con i ragazzi clip tau che fanno video
su netflix futures che il canale che
sicuramente trovate nella descrizione
l'abbiamo fatto in collaborazione con
netflix per over the move che questo
film d'animazione targato appunto
netflix che trovate non mi ricordo dove
house netflix comunque ragazzi abbiamo
fatto una roba incredibile
guardatevi il video e guardatevi
soprattutto anche over the moon
perché un film pazzesco guarda neanche
il trailer perché merito non fa vi
lascio al video perché sarà incredibile
non faccio mai queste cose e ci sarà un
motivo
capelli capelli cosa volevi dire capelli
che mia mamma ma io devo andare
professore andiamo al mare fastidio
positivo a casa
ragazzi miei ho fatto il tampone il
risultato è uscito negativo
niente li uso per questo video prossimo
in questa zona è più di feliz ma
veramente la materia sembra una domanda
no io non mi presto non proprio guardano
interessi si sono prelato il tutto
troppo trani qualche microfono in mano
questa perversione inserimenti dei peli
ce li ho ma non te li metto adesso vi
facciamo vedere come ti senti
qui abbiamo i ghostbusters
di fare uno strip
il sistema giusto dire mi ha detto
distogliere la felpa in un video di
lanciarla si sono mandati in scena
volevo lanciarli
allora ti sei brava a fare queste cose
io faccio schifo quindi bilanciarla la
valorizzazione del vino che cosa sto per
fare una carta per curarli via chiaro
chiarissimo antisiriana via masi non
accetta quello comunque io sono i fan
ejei praticante si è laureato pratica
che queste cose fino in area romanista
mi ha un fisico però all'esame ha fatto
molto bene stiamo riuscendo nel nostro
intento di offrire
non mi sembra che ci siano infortuni
trovano già fatto degli errori nella cup
non dobbiamo rovinare la casa
o peggio ancora quando siamo andati in
bagno privato la quale abbiamo affidato
la fonte sono compagni ma è bravo non è
vero conosci l'artista canterà carattere
psicologico ha fatto capolino dal m c ha
attaccato una macchina per questo spot
una macchina un auser e anche il suo
curatore attaccato costringerli a punto
della macchina perché notti passate a
cara duro su del genere
vieni attimo ci bastavano per attaccare
con piero si attacca già vergogna
vorrei fare leviosa attaccando il mio
montatore video che stanno male testa le
prende tutte le rapine tutte le radio
brand e volendo quanto sei nello spazio
non c'è bisogno di cambiare straziando
va da solo
[Applauso]
adesso è arrivato il momento di farli
volare sicuramente vi starete chiedendo
perché ci servono qui carbonato di aceto
e 9
la combinazione di accese di carbonato
crea diossido di carbonio anche detto
allegri le loro battute tutte queste
fasce ma no ma mi sto scrostando
addirittura dal dito
io sono pittura credito cose che
capitano quando fai un razzo di carta 10
euro alla mano contro la presenza bello
che purtroppo sta accettando ma so che
ha il 99 per cento di vittoria dove
questi fortini cardigans fai a queste un
cardigan con meccanica spar di gaza un
cardigan stadi roba che sono nei
commenti cos'è un tram di gara di roba
elegante scrivete lo stato chiederà
stato nei commenti se sapete cos'è un
cardigan allo ragazzi iniziamo con il
mio raggio che mettono a favore di
camera perché la parte dietro non è
pitturata non lo diciamo 32 19
io in atto e per la migliore l'hai messo
rivolto verso di noi sei matta di chi
secondo me sì lo scopriremo tra un
messaggio
i ragazzi lo sappiamo proprio poi anche
era un vero già scherzo bellissimo e
quindi ragazzi questo era è stato più o
meno certo ripeto quando raso mi è morto
comunque i ragazzi vi dico la verità è
un ragazzo proprio simpatico grazie dopo
di assalito radici piero entrato nel
video giampiero non è entrato nel video
e loro non so se lo monta bene non lo so
che devo fare
e devo fare ora ti faccio un montaggi
know adesso le cuoia sono giampiero
quindi così ti impegni ex mister ho
finito
[Musica]